en tunisie la colère des magistrats ne
retombe pas après la dissolution du
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
parc high side le président tunisien
estime avoir mis fin à un organe
corrompus une partie de la communauté
internationale s'élèvent contre cette
décision la correspondance à tunis signé
ben hassen chébili
décision anticonstitutionnelle ou
nécessité absolue de sauver le pays si
la dissolution du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature et depuis deux jours au
coeur de toutes les préoccupations
qu'elles soient nationales ou
internationales c'est depuis le
ministère de l'intérieur dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche que cahill sayyed a
annoncé la dissolution de l'organe
judiciaire et qu'il juge partiale et
corrompu de quoi susciter l'inquiétude
de l'association des magistrats
tunisiens qui a dénoncé cette volonté
d'un homme a concentré entre ses mains
le pouvoir judiciaire une remise en
cause de la séparation des pouvoirs a
également brocardé par l'opposition à
commencer par le parti islamiste ennahda
qui a qualifié ce coup de portes de
préambule à l'instauration d'une
dictature des réactions relayé à
l'international hier les états unis et
l'union européenne qui suivent de très
près le développement de la situation et
l'évolution de l'expérience démocratique
en tunisie ont mis en garde locataire du
palais de carthage quant aux dangers
d'une telle décision écouter les
etats-unis sont profondément préoccupés
par l'appel du président tunisien sayyed
à dissoudre le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature et par les informations
selon lesquelles des employés n'auraient
pas accès au conseil supérieur de la
magistrature une justice indépendante
est un élément crucial d'une démocratie
efficace et transparente il est
essentiel que le gouvernement de tunisie
tienne ses engagements à respecter
l'indépendance de la justice
conformément à la constitution nous
suivons avec précaution l'évolution de
la situation en tunisie y compris les
récentes annonces du président de la
république sur la dissolution du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
tout en respectant la souveraineté du
peuple tunisien nous rappelons une fois
de plus l'importance de la séparation
des pouvoirs et de l'indépendance
judiciaire en tant qu'élément clé pour
la démocratie la stabilité et la
prospérité du pays des réformes
substantielles comme celle ci aussi
importante et nécessaire qu'elle puisse
être doivent être le résultat processus
inclusif et transparent
sur ordre du gouvernement tunisien les
forces de sécurité intérieure ont
procédé hier à la fermeture du siège de
l'instance indépendante interdisant à
quiconque d'y pénétrer et ce jusqu'à
nouvel ordre son président youssef
bouzar caire a dénoncé une fermeture
illégale par la force dans le but de
s'emparer des institutions de l'état du
côté de la présidence aucune réaction
l'homme fort de la tunisie faisant fi de
toutes critiques et mises en garde
semble plus que jamais déterminé à
maintenir le cap de son coup de force du
25 juillet dernier au risque de voir
grossir les rangs des opposants et kaïs
ayed a déclaré travailler sur un décret
provisoire de réorganisation du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature et lui qui
depuis 7 mois gouverne seul par décrets
présidentiels un pays au bord de
l'implosion sociale et économique